haley thank you i'd like to ask you
about the woodward interviews
did president trump intentionally
mislead the american people about the
threat of covet a pandemic that has now
caused the lives of nearly 200 000
americans absolutely not
this president at a time when you're
facing insurmountable
challenges it's important to express
confidence it's
important to express calm please play it
down it's playing it down is that is
that expressing calm
it seems dishonest can you read the rest
of the quote that's how much they put
in there oh you excluded the last part
um we'll play the full thing on six
please
please do it do you have to explain
please of course i deny that
and he makes clear that he doesn't want
to see chaos by the way is the second
part of the quote which you failed to
read
the president just days after having
this discussion
with bob woodward said this from this
podium on march 30th he said
i do want them to stay calm we are doing
a great job if you look at the
individual statements they're all true
stay calm
it will go away but it's important to
stay calm so this president
does what leaders do good leaders it
stay calm
and resolute at a time when you face an
insurmountable challenge that's what
this president hates it will not appear
that the president
lied to the american public about the
threat posed by kovitz the president has
never lied to the american public
on covid the president's been very the
president was expressing calm and his
actions reflect that
on january 6 the cdc issued a wuhan
travel notice before any confirmed us
cases
among another a number of other actions
and i'd refer you to
dr falchi who said that this president
has an impressive response
i can't imagine under any circumstance
that anyone could be doing anything more
that is the record of this president